We thought that we understood
when we started this journey that,
okay, cars are very expensive,
let's design a cheaper car, you know.
There are many, many other challenges
in racing and we learn them mainly
by operating a racing series.
Tamir Plachinsky, thank you
for joining me on to the leaders.
Good afternoon to both of us.
Thank you.
Happy to be here.
Okay. Before we start,
I need you to tell me
about this background.
What am I seeing here?
Yeah. It's cool ah.
What you see is the different
user interfaces of our data platform,
which we call ramp.
A data platform
developed for motorsports.
This is what Griiip is now involved in
focusing in the different screens.
So, in order for me to even begin
to try and understand
what I'm seeing here,
like I mentioned before we started,
I don't know the difference between
the Toyota and the KIA and Hyundai.
To me, they're all bare metals
on four wheels
that get me from point A to point B,
but I really appreciate people
that have a passion for it.
So, Tamir,
tell me, before we start talking about
racing cars, how do you get started
with an industry like this?
What type of upbringing do you have
where you get so passionate
about race cars?
Yeah.
So, the key word here is
exactly what you said.
It's passion.
And you cannot
describe or explain passion.
Either you have it or either you don't.
And a lot of people in the world
apparently have this kind of passion for
cars, for driving, for driving fast,
for the adrenaline, for the excitement,
racing, motorsport, all those things,
which exist in motorsport.
Motorsport is like
the sport for those who love
driving and cars and everything.
And I think for me personally,
it's something that I have
since I can remember
since I was a little boy.
And growing up in Israel,
being passionate about motorsport
is not a very nice thing to do
because in the Israel,
there is no motorsport.
That was I was about to ask.
Right.
I don't see, you know,
I just came back from Dubai.
Every second street I go
there's a line up
of Ferraris and Lamborghinis.
I don't remember seeing
even a single Lamborghini here in Israel.
Yeah. Those exotic sports cars
are one thing, but you don't have any
motorsport culture in Israel.
It's like you don't have race or
race car manufacturers or industry
or anything like that.
That actually, it was illegal
until around 2015.
So, in Israel,
you only see that in the news
and in newspapers and TV,
but you don't really get to be
involved in such an activity.
And that's something
I've always wanted to do.
So growing up, I had the dream
to become a world champion.
That was my dream, driving something
motorcycle, race car or whatever.
But you come to the understanding
that when you're 21, after,
you know, serving in the military,
it's a bit late to start your career.
So I went to study mechanical engineering
in the university with the dream to get
to become involved in the industry.
I described it to myself back then
as being involved in the
automotive industry.
And I wanted to go to Italy.
That was like a country I saw
as the best place to go and do that.
Ferrari or Lamborghini,
I didn't really care.
And then it became reality when
during my studies I started
the formula student team.
It's like a team of students
developing race cars
for a student competition.
You race against other universities.
Wow.
I started the first team in Israel
back in 2010.
And then we went to an event in Italy
with the team.
It was totally underground project.
No one in the university
really knew knew what we were doing.
We tested the car
in an abandoned parking lots at night.
It was really one day will do
and we will make a movie on that here.
And then going to Italy for the event
I met the main sponsor
of the competition
was a race car company from Italy
and they offered me a job.
So, I fulfilled my dream
and I went to work
in motorsport and race car manufacturer.
The best one in the world,
called Dallara.
Spent six months
living the dream completely,
as you can imagine.
And then coming back to Israel,
i was so hyped about, okay,
I know what I want to do.
I love racing. I love race car.
Let's do something in Israel
in motorsport.
And I saw only advantages
in the fact that there is no industry
in Israel in motorsport.
You can only,
if you have no constraints,
you can do whatever you want.
100%. Right.
Tamir, before we continue,
I have to get a little bit
of a better understanding about
motorsports as an industry
even before we get to
to what you're doing with Griiip.
Because to an outsider,
all I can think about is that
in some places
there was a race cars.
There's these crazy people
that get into these crazy fast cars
that are driving around in circles
to beat the fastest time.
What is this industry all about?
What is the excitement?
Give me some numbers.
Who is the audience?
What does it take to get there?
I really am curious about this.
Yeah. That's a good question.
So, motor sport is probably,
I think I won't offend anyone by saying
that it's the most complex sport
in the world.
You don't only have the athlete,
you have also the machine.
And it's about the man machine
integration that eventually win this.
And it's harder to understand
as a viewer, as a fan.
Because it's not like you have a ball.
You need to throw it,
you have a score.
This is a, it's more complex.
You need to understand
why this driver is faster than the other.
There are a lot, a lot of things
that you don't catch
with the untrained eye.
And also you have, let's say in a race,
10, 20, 50 cars,
it doesn't matter the number,
but as the number of cars
are the number of potential events
happening every second.
On a football game or basketball,
you have one ball.
All the eyes are looking at that ball.
And what happened with the ball
is the event going on.
In a race, you have a lot of cars.
Everyone can do something.
So, you have many balls.
So, it's much difficult to understand.
But still watching cars
going fast on a track,
it's a very exciting thing.
That the battle, you know that
it's the risk factor back then
when it started and make the sport much,
very much like gave
the interesting factor to it.
You know they are risking their lives.
And unfortunately,
we can still see drivers
getting hurt on the track,
even though safety became
much, much better than it was used to be.
But the combination of speed and risk
and sound and everything
is like a spectacular,
like no other sport, at least in my mind.
But being that complex
with the facilities and the cars or
motorcycles and everything,
it's a very expensive sport.
And that's like a big, big
negative thing for the industry
because you always want to have
as many drivers
and as many people participating.
But there is the money barrier in motorsport
that you need to have a lot of money.
Money plays
a very big role in motorsports.
Right?
You actually surprised me
when I talked about the,
the human machine integration
that that is a key to success.
And I always imagined that, you know,
yeah, you have the top players,
the top athletes.
I didn't even think of them as athletes.
I thought of them, okay,
they're really great
hand eye coordination, and then
whoever gets the best car wins.
But what you're saying
is that it actually
it's the combination of the car specs
and the driver's specific skill sets
that if they're aligned, that's what
is causing the special circumstance.
Right?
It's not just that if the car is better
then that's it, they win.
Yeah.
If you look at the different
racing series in the world,
that balance varies from, let's say,
Formula One,
there are different manufacturers.
And we look at Formula One as a series
where the car has more
effect on the final result result.
If you look at lower
tier series, let's say
even what we call single maker series
where all the cars are identical,
but you can still
do different setups for the car.
So that's where the drivers talent comes.
That makes a lot of sense.
So, I'm looking at a dashboard.
And I have no idea
why we would need a dashboard
for motor racing industry.
Tell me about this.
Of course, I'm teasing when I say that I,
that there are lot of the things
that I don't understand.
But it's too complicated
for me to understand,
but I wish I understood it better.
So,
I think, by the way, this dashboard
as like a mirror.
Because I think,
I see the English they're brights up.
I think I'm seeing it okay.
Yeah.
So it's like, uh, I'm sitting behind it.
I know it's something in the front.
I will explain the dashboard
by continuing like this short history
about Griiip.
So, Griiip,
when I came back to Israel,
I started Griiip as a brand
to make motor sport more accessible.
I just finished my last
explanation saying that
it's very expensive.
And that's where we saw
Griiip comes in the market
offering something different.
Like we wanted to give more people
opportunity to participate.
And we started maybe not in the most
common place to start,
but we started with the driver.
And we said, okay,
let's give the driver
a better solution to race,
a more cost effective solution.
So we started by designing a race car.
It's not a very simple thing to do
for a small startup.
Small startup from a country
with no motor sport, with no racetracks,
with no knowledge.
It was pretty intense.
But, you know,
you set up to do something
and you are very determined,
so, that's what you do.
And we eventually,
we designed the race car.
Started the racing series in Italy.
That's the series you see
in the picture.
And that's like on board
from that series.
That was a single maker series
only for our cars.
The car, by the way,
we call it the model name is G1
and the series was the G1 series.
It ran for two years.
And during those two years
we learned a lot about motorsport.
We thought that we understood
when we started this journey that
okay, cars are very expensive.
Let's design a cheaper car, you know.
There are many, many other challenges
in racing and we learn them mainly
by operating a racing series.
And we couldn't know that
before we started  this racing series.
You can imagine
an Israeli manufacturer of racing cars
runs a series in North Italy.
it's not the most common thing
you'll hear.
By the way, how does this work?
So you designed the cars,
you manufacture the cars,
and then you have to go
and pitch those cars
as a series to drivers
to come and drive them to compete?
Is that how it works?
Yeah. Something like that.
Yeah. You need to start
building your connections and
get to know more teams and more drivers
and convince them that your series
have a value for them
because it has a lower barrier for entry
and it's very fast the cars
and you have a lot of exposure.
So people will see you
if you want to start your career
and stuff like that.
But starting that we were very focused
on the series when we started
back in 2018.
But again, we wanted to,
we we were a very,
we were still but back then,
we were a very small
young tech company and we thought, okay,
what else we can do
to make our cars better,
to differentiate them from other cars.
And we wanted
to give the drivers the ability to not
need to hire experts to help him improve.
Because motorsports,
like it's very data centric sport.
You need to rely on data to improve.
It's not as simple as kicking
a ball into the goal or something.
Even in that area, we are starting
to see more and more data coming in.
Right.
Motorsport on the cars,
you have a lot of sensors already
and you need to know
how to use that data to improve.
And drivers usually don't know that.
You need to hire that expert to do that.
And we said, okay, we can
go around that expert
and give the driver those tips
on how to improve automatically.
If we make all the cars connected
we upload the data
we analyze the data in real time
and we give that to the drivers.
And that's where we started
developing our data platform.
Again, it was for the driver.
We had the dream.
Like, imagine you're driving
and you're seeing,
like you hear what you need to improve
or you see that
on the dashboard of something.
But the car teaches you.
That's what we wanted to do.
But then we started the series.
We understood that this solution
is not limited only for the driver
because it's a series.
You want to also differentiate yourself.
You want to attract viewers
that will bring sponsors,
that will bring more drivers.
[--]
So, yeah, exactly.
Down spiral. You did the exact
motion that we are doing.
And Marco, our EVP of Media Solutions,
will be super proud when he see you.
Because this is what he do,
does all the time. Anyway,
so, we understood that
we have a solution here
that no one has
and no one else developed that yet.
We looked for other solutions.
We couldn't find anyone, anything.
And then we thought, okay,
that's what we need to do.
We need to develop
that platform for racing.
And this is where we like
we saw the light
and we didn't look back since.
And that's what you're seeing around.
And like and my background,
you see different user interfaces,
like the data augmentation we do
for the linear TV broadcast,
the overview screen
that if you're a driver
you can go and see where you are
compared to other drivers.
The briefing screens
for the drivers to see where they do
what they did good or bad.
And a second stream viewing
interface for the end users
or the viewers and many more.
And that's what we're doing now.
We are also implementing
the connectivity to eSports,
which is a crazy thing because
this is also something unique
for motorsport in racing.
And unlike other sports,
the game that you play is similar
completely to driving a car,
except for the acceleration.
Because you sit at home
with your steering wheel
and the pedals, you can buy a kit.
It's not expensive.
But when you play NBA 2K
or FIFA.
You don't have a basketball and a hoop, right?
No, no.
You cannot see yourself
going on the court
with LeBron James
and going to play against him.
But if you are a super thin driver,
actually, you can go on track.
You need to be fit and race with the best
and you'll see your fast.
I can already imagine
the virtual reality headsets
that are already placing you in there with
potentially vibrating chair
that can mimic the acceleration.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
So that's what we call
mixed reality races.
And this is something the platform
is going to also because it's
a data platform eventually.
And we can collect data from cars,
we collect the data from simulators.
It's the same thing
and we merge them together.
Wow.
That's just unbelievable.
And so, tell me a little bit about
the future of the racing sport, because
cars are becoming more autonomous.
I'm watching
the different cars on the road like Tesla
already advertising that they go
to zero to 60 in three seconds.
Is this going to affect
in any way racing?
Are we ever going to see autonomous cars
racing each other, you know,
potentially also against humans?
So, you'll be surprised,
but there are already autonomous cars
racing each other.
There was a thing called the Roborace
and they are autonomous cars
that are racing to each other.
It's pretty cool.
Motorsport traditionally was the,
it acted as development platform
for the automotive industry.
So you see a lot of manufacturers
developing technologies on track.
And then those technologies
are being conveyed to the road cars
that you are using.
And we see that very strongly today
with the electric revolution,
that those electric components are being
taken to the limit on the track
and getting their tracks that stand.
And then you can use that.
So motorsport will play, as I see it,
a very significant role
in the years to come
as the, again,
the place where all those new
technologies will be perfected.
And also, even when
in whenever it comes
and the roads will be filled
with autonomous cars
and you will not be allowed to drive,
I think those islands where you can
experience that human emotion,
that is one of the most amazing.
You know, if you can fly a jet fighter,
maybe it can be more exciting, but
taking a car on on track to the limit
is something that it's crazy.
It's amazing experience.
And I don't see that disappear.
I hope never.
Now, I'm going to have to go
and try that for myself
because it sounds exhilarating.
Being a little bit distance from the field,
you never actually imagine yourself there.
But now, I can see why the excitement.
I can see the thrill and I can
more than anything see the potential
of what you're doing here.
A data driven platform for motor racing,
both for the driver,
but also for the game,
for the player at home,
for the viewer on the TV and for the team
that is debriefing after and also
the manufacturer of the car
that wants to see, okay,
how did the driver interact with the car,
what were the limitations,
how did we hold up against others.
I think that you're exactly
on to what it should be
and it's really really impressive.
Thank you, Tamir, for taking the time
to share this with me.
Before we leave,
I have to ask you
for the hardest question.
Three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
I just wanted before I answer,
I have to say
that you describe it perfectly.
Because what we are saying
that we are doing is
creating a digital universe
around racing grants.
You described that universe
of the users so beautiful.
The three words.
Determined, I think.
Creative.
Yeah.
Optimistic. Energetic.
I don't know.
Yeah, I think the first two
were much easier.
That's why it's the hardest question.
And I'll take all those four or five words.
All those seem to me makes perfect sense.
But I think that the first two are
the strong, like what I say,
I think can describe myself the best.
100%. The story of growing up in Israel
with practically no industry,
but yet you have the passion
and motivation to go there,
creating this grassroots program within
Ben Gurion University in Beer Sheva,
the team that is going to race
with the car in Italy,
going to land a job
in Italy, coming back,
starting a company based in Israel
that creates a series in Italy.
I mean,
the whole stories of determination
and perseverance
and creativity above it all.
So, thank you, Tamir,
again for the inspiration.
This was wonderful. Toda raba.
And stay safe and healthy.
Yeah.
My pleasure and honor.
Thank you.